[Musique]
françois quel âge as-tu 17 ans nuit
alors qu'elle quitte à amener ici
différents vols
quand j'étais à paris mais c'est du vol
d'argent surtout
plus important c'est qu'en voyage d'une
librairie c'est ce qui m'a mené 6-4
qu'avec interfel quand il ya de la
librairie 14 ans 14 et 7 est ta première
infraction pour premier délit non on a
vu d'autres a vendu le vol d'argent
aussi tu allais de la fla je travaillais
bonne augure pour celle que je vais
apprécier d'accord tu te fais pas le
commun le libraire est sentie nous on
partait tranquillement librairie sorte
ils crient au secours femmes au canada
de cesser bron moi j'ai réussi à le
redire je pars dit plus vite que lui qua
non est obligé de dire non non adressée
par l'ate a pris contact avec la prison
non non pour ça nous on m'a mis à sa vie
et ses combats on a relâché on m'a donné
une convocation du juge
j'étais au bureau du juge le juge m'a
donné un avertissement pour ont fait m'a
dit que si je travaillais pas loin dans
le mois qui suivaient ont fermé et j'ai
pas travailler en moins après l'émission
présentée par donner un avertissement et
la troisième fois c'était la bonne à la
troisième fois qu'est ce que c'était
abbas était toujours nous parce que je
travaillais promet je connaissais des
vols un peu partout or des fois il me
faisait prendre des fois non qui forment
soupçonné finalement les montres nie en
bloc
puis après je fréquentais ils ont une
banque
beaucoup plus nombreuse conneries
ensemble ce qui les définit c'est qu'ils
sont dans la rue qu'ils s'emmerdent à
longueur de journée physiquement à
longueur de journée ils sont enracinées
dans cet enduit et que si vous voulez
ils ne peuvent pas ils ne peuvent non
plus physiquement pas dit physiquement
ni psychologiquement prendre leur place
dans une société où ils soient reconnus
leur journée
c'est beaucoup de vide c'est c'est ne
rien faire de toute la journée il se
lève vers midi
il mange il peut généralement il peut
quand même et puis il va dans la rue
retrouver les copains pour trouver une
fille temps en temps et puis dans la rue
il ne se passe rien dire qu'ils sont
entre eux ils parlent ils inventent il
affabule il raconte des coûts qu'ils ont
fait où ils s'inventent même ils vivent
dans un monde qui les caractérise
beaucoup c'est qu'ils vivent dans un
monde fantasmagorique et si vous voulez
ce qui définit me semble très bien leur
vie quotidienne c'est que le débouché
naturel de l'état de blousons noirs pour
reprendre cette terminologie ça n'est
pas du tout le gangstérisme
c'est la cloche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
le plupart du temps je crois ce qui me
frappe c'est l'absence de travail assidu
je crois que c'est cette oisiveté qui
est la cause du mal je crois que les
jeunes ne sont pas assez occupé ou ne
savent pas s'occuper
on ne veulent pas s'occuper des bahamas
a un bac s es toi-même
pourquoi de ma porte et j'ai vu que ça
servait à rien de travailler c'est tout
je prenais mes copains le problème est
pourquoi ce genre c'est bien ce que tu
cherches et fer de classe des filles
oui cartier à paris seulement mort à
saint germain 3 malle contient lui doit
des géants comme ailleurs évidemment il
ya beaucoup de mouvement il ya beaucoup
de jeunes beaucoup de beatniks desouki
ça les gens n'aiment pas beaucoup il
trouve que ça fait
non mais enfin je trouve c'est un
quartier comme les autres tout comme ça
qu'est ce que tu fais là en ce moment
mais les verts
spécialiste de boire débité quoi je vais
voir dave et nick ont été un peu vite il
est charmant
est-ce que tu habites
fâché de marseille
9e temps qu à paris
et à saint geours
ce que tu as fait qu'un danger
damman
ce cas votre pognon c'est la manche et
faire la main en chantant que j'ai mangé
mon dieu si on veut ça vous fait pas de
mal de morgane l'habitude
en quoi ça consiste de s'amuser à sa
jambe nous sommes usés vous peu traîné
jusqu'à 4 5 heures du matin on voit
toujours du monde dans les rues
le plaisir d'être aimé ouais quelle
heure tu vas rentrer chez toi tant de
calais le matin demain matin qu'est ce
que tu fais à paris rien tu dors la
journée
dans la journée on s'enlève
saint-germain-des-prés dru parlons en
fait c'était le quartier latin
traditionnel ça c'est à la fois sur le
5e et le 6e arrondissement
et puis il y a eu évidemment l'époque
glorieuse de saint germain des prés des
années d'après guerre
est-ce que c'est cela qui
psychologiquement inciter les jeunes à
venir sur le secteur est ce que c'est
l'ancien quartier latin mais en tout cas
il est certain que maintenant c'est
constitué surtout ce secteur un ensemble
propre à attirer les jeunes
les commerçants ont voulu attirer les
jeunes par soit les soit les vêtements
soient que mon dirais-je tout ce qui
intéresse la jeunesse par des ventes
d'objets divers intéressant les gens et
on retrouve là un des problèmes de cette
masse de jeunes gens qui est arrivé à
éclosion à la suite des événements de la
guerre la seconde guerre mondiale qui
est arrivé éclosion
un peu plus à notre époque et qui
aboutit à apporter au commerce un marché
à conquérir
on a voulu être jeune et on a voulu
former un monde à part et on en a je
crois l'illustration à ce jour nicoletta
vous avez bien connu cette villa comment
avez vous découvert saint germain des
prés à votre sortie de la maison de
rééducation je suis parti j'ai commencé
à vivre la bohème au jour le jour avec
des jeunes j'ai parti en stop sur la
côte d'azur comme ça et comme gecina un
peu à cannes sur la croisette journée
des dessins je faisais on dormait dans
les cabines de plage et là j'ai connu
des gens qui me parlait de paris parce
que je connaissais que la seine et oise
au saint germain des prés c'est
formidable c'est merveilleux tu peux
travailler la nuit c'est très bien puis
je me suis dit après tout lieu de
rentrer au cerveau pourquoi je pousserai
pas mon stop jusqu'à paris et avec une
jeune parisienne
je suis rentré de cas non stop jusqu'à
paris j'ai atterri à 10 heures du soir à
5 octobre
64 je me souviens à paris la nuit en
place un gendre et des prix devant
l'église
volta flore et je n'étais pas du tout
imaginé ça jamais comme ça quand on
connaît pas et j'ai débarqué au au flore
j'ai vu une faune de gens incroyables
très mélangées je savais pas où dormir
et j'avais quinze francs en poche et on
a dormi dans un petit hôtel rumeurs de
touva la russie et va les payer sa fiche
fait payer sa chambre tout de suite et
je me souviens comme profession j'avais
mis un artiste et je savais pas du tout
j'aimerais chanteuse mais comme je
dessinais j'avais mes artistes
c'est marrant et le lendemain je
retournais traîner au flore puis j'ai
fait ça tous les jours
elle j'ai commencé à sortir la nuit
j'étais dans les boîtes
je dormais chez l'un chez l'autre des
jeunes comme moi qui travaillais pas
pour vous de 15 jours j'avais vraiment
rien pour manger
je n'ai pas quoi faire alors je traîne
est vraiment jusqu'à 6h 7h du matin je
buvais des café crème dans les cafés à
midi j'allais faire ma toilette j'ai des
copines qui pouvaient pas mais berger et
l'argent j'en avais pas le café les
cafés aux débrouillait aux ouvriers
entre nous on vivait au crochet les uns
les autres et après j'ai eu la charge de
travail et comme vestiaire dans un club
où des ciseaux jeux pan d'éléments tome
donné un front large 3 et là j'étais
payé à la journée j'ai payé ma petite
chambre d'hôtel et j'ai vécu comme ça
des tas de moi c'est très facile de
vivre à saint germain des prés sans
travail et il suffit de ne pas avoir
trop de conscience et de se plier au
goût du jour
ils mendient ils font quelques petits
des livres commettre quelques petits
délits seul ou en bande et aussi une
satisfaction vis de personnes très
riches
qui les paient généreusement
puis solliciter quelques fois pour faire
des vous parlez oui beaucoup surtout il
sait quel genre de course du trafic qui
fêtera si je le devrais oui la drogue
beaucoup dans le quartier soit il ya un
problème qui est un problème de
contagion à l'heure actuelle c'est celui
de la drogue qui a été introduite chez
nous par les hippies et qui pique nique
qui semble avoir fait des ravages c'est
important sur toute une population
c'est là un problème essentiellement
d'ordre public évidemment puisque je
savais à quel point ça peut être grave
pour le moment il ya des bus si on en
juge par ce qui se passe dans certains
pays nordiques c'est un problème très
inquiétant est certain qu'il faudra
employer des moyens très fort et très
puissant pour arrêter ce véritable fléau
parce que en dehors des les plaisirs
d'intellectuels que certains peuvent
tirer de ce genre d'histoire les suites
sont toujours catastrophiques
spécialement sur des jeunes pas solide
je suis bien au courant de ces affaires
de drogue ce c'est terrible parce que
ils goûtent et pour eux c'est un c'est
comme à remontant un stimulant parce que
certains d'ailleurs des jeunes des très
jeunes se vante de ne pas dormir pendant
des nuits des nuits en prenant de la
drogue et pour un rien maintenant vous
achetez un petit peu de drogue
ce soit du haschich que ce soit une
herbe quelconque pour ce soit un produit
pharmaceutique pour cinq fois où vous
avez un cube de haschisch
comment sont les jeunes que vous arrêtez
kitsch en drogué dans les vapes comme on
peut je peux employer ce terme dans les
vapes ils sont ils sont bien ils sont
favoris dit vous répondre gentiment ils
sont ils sont bien et
puis tout d'un coup il ya une période
d'abattement et qui est terrible il
s'effondre
il pense plus qu'à une chose ça à dormir
ca à dormir à se reposer et puis qui
bafouille beya c'est l'abattement cédric
pourquoi pour passer le temps
ni plus ni moi ou pour eux pour
connaître pour savoir
alors je crois vous avez aussi dans
votre quartier notre quartier de
prédilection
sager 1 une autre forme de délinquance
juvénile qui est la prostitution et la
prostitution sous deux formes la
prostitution les garçons et la
prostitution des filles
c'est un problème dans le sens que les
jeunes ne veulent pas travailler dès
qu'ils connaissent la vie nocturne des
hauts lieux de la capitale
ils veulent vivre facilement est alors
certain qu'ils s'en servit par leur
physique
ce reste allait à la prostitution
masculine
et l'argent pour manger pour sa vie y
est on se débrouille
c'est à dire chez les français c'est
difficile à dire personnel et bien
habillés et les belles chaussures à vos
régions
de l'homme pourquoi celui qui veut ça
fait pas très chaud
chez les hommes et 10 comment fait-il je
crois oui je me fais invités facilement
dans une boîte
comment et par qui par des titres par
des filles par n'importe qui c'est à
dire de chaque quartier on se saborder
facilement il ya des posies jeunes
beaucoup de plus au nord alors la
prostitution féminine chez les jeunes
c'est surtout une prostitution
d'occasions c'est pas une prostitution
apparence une prostitution quand même
c'est cacher c'est à dire on appelle ça
en fait les michetonneuse savoie une
prostitution institut est notoire c'est
la fille qui cède aux avances d'un
monsieur et qui on lui fait comprendre
qu'elle est un petit peu démuni en ce
moment si ce monsieur pouvait la
dépanner ça l'arrangerait bien ni plus
ni moins
c'est ça en fait c'est un remerciement
un cadeau on vit un peu comme un garçon
et le partage au lit n'importe qui pour
se loger
on peut aussi pour se loger arriver à
faire l'amour avec quelqu'un je le dis
cruel parce qu'on en a marre d'être seul
et on a une présence près de soi et puis
j'ai aussi parce qu'on est vraiment seul
à tous points de vue
quand on peut payer son hôtel en
montrant un garçon qui lie bedak à venir
chez moi alors c'est pas une solution
puis aussi la constitution ne viennent
facilement comme ça aussi la fille qui
est qu'ils crèvent de faim pendant huit
jours qui peut pas se payer une paire de
bagnon ni même anthony une paire de
chaussures elle trouve un type de 30 ans
qui traîne à saint germain qui est son
métier la journée sa femme des enfants
je donne 50 mille francs tu passe de
trois jours avec moi et beaucoup de
filles qu'il faut ça c'est quand même
temps en temps quand elles crèvent de
faim en 3 34 mois et c'est comme ça
qu'on va la prostitution et j'ai eu de
la chance j'ai quand même échappé à sa
gelée quand même côtoyé
alors nadia qu'est-ce qu'on fait saint
germain à 23h45 ou à minuit quand on a
16 ans et on se promène on se ferait de
temps en temps mais celle de sortir mais
quand on a 16 ans et quand on pas
spécialement les papiers qu'il faut on
veut pas rentrer au mans vous quoi je ne
suis pas une niche au nez si je peux
vous dire
que même question s'il ya des misters
balfour leur vie moi je suis une
ouvrière
je ne suis pas une mystérieuse si un
jour j comme marié je serai propres pour
le mariage ce que vous voyez que dans un
an dans deux ans vous pouvez pas devenir
une juste une heure je ne sais pas ce
que je ferais je peux pas dire que ce
que je ne ferai pas bien sûr je suis
content
je ne dis pas que ce n'est pas possible
c'est tout c'est très possible comme
d'ailleurs toutes les filles qu'ils y
sont maintenant c'est c'est
c'est ce qui leur arrive quand même des
gars mais ça pourrait m'arriver rejoint
vous fait peur
oui dans un sens et si ça devait
m'arriver qu'est-ce que vous voulez que
je fasse
coincé entre
je serai par besoin d'argent si j'avais
vraiment besoin d'argent ça serait pour
ma mère pour mes parents vos parents
savent que vous êtes là oui mais si aux
ménuires foot mais sur savent que je
suis a mis nu s agir mans mais simon
matière liberté c'est qu'ils ont
confiance en moi ils savent que si je
vais à sa jeunesse
c'est simplement comment viser ce n'est
pas pour me jeter n'est ni pour faire du
mal à votre avis monsieur le commissaire
quel est le degré de responsabilité des
familles c'est très variable
on ne peut pas d'une part parlait
toujours de culpabilité lorsque on a
affaire des débiles mentaux à des gens
qui vivent dans les conditions
excessivement misérables et qui par
conséquent éprouve de telles difficultés
pour subsister par leurs propres moyens
que la part qu'ils peuvent réserver à
l'éducation de leurs enfants et bien est
vraiment très minime et il n'est pas
étonnant que dans de telles conditions
de vie et bien les garçons des filles de
jeunes adolescents et bien fassent des
bêtises comme le monde mal à me quel âge
avez vous la mère de 65 ans vous avez
des enfants
un livre de monsieur aulas à côté vous
c'est un beau fils que la wii c'est mon
fils tu vois gestion
c'est à dire raison ouais quel âge tu
avais quand tu es surpris moi j'ai
commencé à 15 ans elle a sa vie n'y est
proche
trois fois frêle gt qu'est ce que tu
avais fait simplement des vols de
voitures vols de voiture puis vol de
mobylette des premiers temps je pénètre
ces projectiles volent voiture
ton père ou ta mais je te demande et
parce que tu aurais fait la nuit et vous
madame je me rendais malade qu'est ce
qu'il fait et il n'y a pas eu un
accident j'ai essayé de maurice en tout
surtout je suis déjà cardiaque tout si
je comprends bien c'est dans cette pièce
que vous couchez vous et vos deux
enfants
est ce que vous croyez que si vous aviez
eu une autre vie donc une vraie maison
est ce que vous croyez que christian
votre fils l'aurait sans ciller
ben oui tout parce qu'une belle comme et
poids qui me dit maman vivement qu'on
soit parti d'ici bas prix n'aurait
jamais jeté en prison et y aurait
syndicat n'a jamais volé ne vous posez
pas que cette vote faute à vous mais
c'est de la faute de la façon dont ils
lui c'est à cause de ça qu il soit trop
enfermés mais malheureusement depuis
revenue jamais l'a fait contre monsieur
tout jamais plus jamais des fois il veut
bien dit moment je suis à paris où je
suis à 20 h au cinéma avec un petit
garçon qui jeunes qui t'avait sa côte
est est très gentil sa mère et son
beau-père n'achèterai pas qui fait des
conneries ce qu'ils visitent agassi si
tu fais des conneries christian je te
contribuer les parents on en voudrait
plus c'est lui qui l'a dit c'est exact
se feront plus de bêtises te le jure et
a juré sur notre dame de lourdes et sur
la croix de jésus que jamais il refait
de conneries du tout du tout dans les
milieux vos voisins vous avez aussi des
problèmes de près délinquance et les
problèmes de flux bien entendu nous
avons des problèmes
de délinquance et des problèmes de fûts
de et nous devons aussi intervenir en ce
qui concerne justement ces milieux là
les fugues sont relativement moins
nombreuses mais elles existent elles les
motivations ne sont pas toujours les
mêmes il ya toujours des motivations
identique
par exemple la mauvaise note en classe
parfois poussa jeunes à quitter le
domicile paternel de prendre une
sanction qu'il estime trop sévère mais
il ya aussi l'aventuré amoureuse ou le
désir de vivre sa vie n'est ce pas c'est
beaucoup pas la mode à l'heure actuelle
les jeunes quittent leur milieu familial
parce qu'ils estiment qu'ils y sont même
parfois trop heureux et qu'ils veulent
se lancer eux mêmes pour faire la preuve
de leur propre personnalité
est-ce que vous parents savent que vous
faites n'est pas non plus en plus
mission pas mais sont encore peu connues
vous n'avez pas connu il ya personne
pour vous aider à paris personne
maintenant ils n'habitent pas avec moi
ça fait de moi là je produis je veux les
voir on entend au début oui beaucoup de
questions maintenant je suis trailer est
égale passion ma famille je vois plus
alors non je suis tout seul et c'est
aussi dire à des parents au martray
qu'est-ce qu'il faut s'en séparer s'agit
d'une adaptation est finalement un
problème plus personne à part quelques
inadaptation global pourrait-on dire lié
au milieu social la plupart sont des
inadaptations personnel c'est à dire que
sont essentiellement liées d'abord à la
famille mais familles n'ont pas
forcément responsable sur le plan
éducatif mais park sont des familles qui
sont elles mêmes troubles et les parents
névrosé ou des parents alcooliques ou
des parents souffrent de maladies
mentales héréditaires
ça se voit ou alors on met une une
désagrégation de la cellule familiale
je jouais en la désagrégation de la
cellule familiale avec quelquefois moins
dangereuse que nous cellule familiale
qui dure avec des troubles de la
personnalité très profond cellules qui
est détruite
dans l'inconscient si je peux dire dans
la profondeur beaucoup plus
traumatisante que certaines familles
matériellement séparé c'est à dire c'est
à dire que les conflits profonds par
exemple entre les deux parents même
s'ils continuent à habiter ensemble sont
beaucoup plus dangereux pour l'équilibré
des enfants que la vie plus calme qui
peut régner entre certains groupes qui
ont réussi à se séparer à moindre frais
les enfants payent toujours la
séparation c'est sûr mais il la paye
moins quand les gens ne se dispute pas
ou quand les gens n'ont pas de ces
comportements
inconsciemment antagonistes dont les
enfants font toujours les frais emmanuel
vous avez trente ans vous avez selon la
tradition familiale
une très belle situation mais depuis
trois ans notre famille est plongé dans
un drame parce que votre jeune frère
votre unique frère a commis l'un des
délits les plus graves qu'un adolescent
puisse commettre
qu'est ce qui a pu amener un garçon de
l'âge de votre frère il avait 17 ans je
crois à faire ce qu'il a fait il
faudrait remonter assez loin
en gros jusqu'à
l'époque où il y avait 12 ans il a été
mis à la porte d'une institution privée
après sa première mise à la porte
il a perdu pas mal de camarades et
finalement ça commence à être un paria
ayant été mis à la porte donc les
parents de ses camarades du milieu une
femme ne voulait pas qu'ils rencontrent
françois petit à petit il a bien fallu à
100 à son âge il fallait bien qu'ils
trouvent des camarades et les à chercher
ailleurs
il les a trouvés c'est symptomatique à
chaque fois il y avait la foire quand on
paie les autres et chaque fois que la
foire venait il commençait à faire des
bêtises
et là il a rencontré pas mal de type
qu'ils ont entraînées qu'ils l'ont
poussé en disant tu es fils de bourgeois
tu dois avoir de l'argent il trop de
l'argent il à chercher de l'argent de
différentes façons et il est arrivé le
dernier histoire j'ai l'impression que
quand vous parlez du cadre à deux frères
vont essayer le rejeter sur sa vie
extérieure les raisons du drame qui a
plongé votre famille
est ce que la famille ne se sent pas
responsable certainement parce qu'il ya
on aurait pu éviter beaucoup de choses
et ça soit mon père ma mère ou moi
maintenant c'est très facile à dire
on verrait pas laisser faire ça on
l'aurait empêché de faire quelque chose
dans l'arrêt ce copain là on leur a mis
à la porte plus vite on l'aurait refusée
à la maison ça ne serait pas arrivé
c'est facile à dire après enfin de toute
façon nous nous sentons coupables vie la
mort vous avez été très bien élevé vous
avez réussi dans la vie vous avez d'une
à être étonné de voir le comportement
votre frère j'ai reçu exactement la même
éducation que mon frère il ya un moment
où il ya eu une bifurcation
il ya plusieurs explications 45
milliards
sûrement je suis d'accord fréquentation
aussi les fréquentations de l'ont poussé
à faire ça il ya eu l'éducation enfin
l'information scolaire
cependant on pourrait trouver énormément
de raison est ce que vous vous l'avez
pris comme un grand frère en lui disant
voilà qu'ils continueraient te donner
une raclée magistral je n'ai jamais
voulu donner cette raclée magistral
parce que je me connais je suis nerveux
je ne sais pas pas plus m'arrêter mais
j'ai au moins avertit dix fois vingt
fois où cinquante fois je suis coupable
jusqu à quel stade assyriens
c'est pas moins de juger plusieurs fois
j'ai retrouvé dans sa chambre en train
de lire des petits bouquins ridicule
diabolique satanique terrifie corim
enfin le capteur qui sont vendues en
vente libre que n'importe qui peut
acheter
il peut acheter n'importe quel livre
cochon il peut aller à la foire comme il
veut un film interdit aux moins de 18
ans plusieurs fois j'ai vu sortir d'un
cinéma interdit ou un film interdit aux
moins de 18 ans alors qu'il n'avait que
16 ans il a été dans des bistrots où il
a consommé geôles c'est parce que le
non ce lieu me l'a dit il a consommé des
cognacs whisky et alors qu'il n'avait
que 16 ans ça fait déjà au moins quatre
exemples qui prouvent que n'importe qui
peut faire n'importe quoi
[Musique]
il a longtemps volé les voitures
pourquoi la voiture la bourse est en
temps parce que des voitures y en a
partout
on a tous les mètres de trottoirs sont
occupés à paris que moment lieu par des
voitures et puis ensuite la voiture
c'est je sais pas moi c'est l'extérieur
l extériorisation d'une france depuis
cent ans on vole surtout des voitures
puissantes
on vole des voitures de sport car c'est
plus agréable et puis on peut faire de
la vitesse il ya le maniaque une fée de
la vitesse y est celui qui veut épater
les copains parce que avec une voiture
ont fait monter des copains et puis on
n'est pas que les filles c'est monter
les filles on a l'impression d'être un
peu assure hamon vient de piloter une
voiture qui vous appartient pas bien sûr
mais on est fort de ce nouvel état et on
est prêt d'autres actions délictuelle
importantes comme le vol et puis alors
la voiture ça sert aussi à ramener des
filles ça sert éventuellement aux
attentats sexuelle ça sert à tout
parce que ce décor de prison
handicap dans la rééducation que vous
avez à faire sur ces jeunes délinquants
il est bien évident que le décor de la
prison créée à une contrainte écrit à
une ambiance toute particulière et que
le problème de la rééducation ne peuvent
pas être abordés d'une manière aussi
efficace que dans un centre ouvert mais
il faut bien se rendre compte que les
garçons qui sont ici sont des garçons
récidiviste pour la plupart ils arrivent
en prison c'est pratiquement inéluctable
en raison de tous les délits qu'ils ont
commis la quantité de délits ou alors de
la gravité du délit commis mais le fait
que nous soyons là constitue pour est la
dernière chose une autre chance car
notre but et notre travail ici
la finalité de notre travail ici c'est
de tenter encore un reclassement dans la
mesure où c'est possible
ainsi nous avons eu des parricides qui
sont arrivés à fresnes c'est un crime
très grave et nous avons pu les faire
sortir de prison avant qu'il ne passe en
cour d'assises et amorcer un
reclassement d'ores et déjà à partir de
quel âge un enfant peut-il être enfermé
dans la prison revient à partir de 13
ans d'après la loi
en général il est rare d'avoir un enfant
de 13 ans ici là l'âge le plus bas et le
plus courant étant un peu plus de 15 ans
ils sont enfermés dans leur chambre
le matin de 7 heures jusqu'à 9 heures où
il y a évidemment les travaux de
nettoyage prendre le petit déjeuner et
ensuite de midi de 11h30 à 14h et le
soir de 18 heures à 19 heures ensuite
dans les intervalles ils vont soit en
atelier soit en classe ou en éducation
physique et sport
puis rocla je tue ses angles et qu'est
ce qui t'a amené ici afin vol de voiture
combien de temps qu ici ça va faire 4
semaines la vie je crois que tu restes
là j'ai souvent enfermé dans ce champ
assez dur surtout que moi j'avais
beaucoup l'esprit de liberté toujours
voir ces baroudeurs vont fermer toujours
dans la chambre alain c'est la première
fois que tu vas en prison oui puisque tu
as fais toi provenir de vols de voiture
puis décale des mobylettes
tu as souvent la fenêtre comme ça ici tu
regardes la vie qui leur est souvent les
oiseaux mangent et on reste ici là
derrière les barreaux puis on va déjà
dit les avions même les gens qui vont
l'autre côté dans la ville
il faut on entend le train ça fait
quelque chose on traite déjà dehors donc
arrivé pour la première fois que lui
cette prison qu'elle ait fait ça te fait
au début je la croyais pas comme ça je
croyais plutôt encore plus strictes on
restait toujours dans la dans la chambre
on mangeait pas beaucoup
fallait se mettre en rang dans la cour
pendant des heures on a quand même la
liberté malgré qu'on soit dans la
cellule on descend dehors on peut dire
ce qu'on pense on parle avec des
camarades ou des fois il laisse les
chambres ouvertes on va dans les étages
le tissu depuis combien de temps il n 10
jours et quel âge vous avez saison
qu'est ce que j'avais fait pour venir
ici de voitures mais vous même je vais
vous la voler la voiture
pourquoi je vous laisse voiture parce
que je sais ce que tu mois ayant des
ennuis avec mes parents parce que mes
parents parce que ma mère boire à quel
âge vous êtes venu à fresnes pour la
première et ensemble c'est souvent ceux
qui sont dehors des temps c'est
quelquefois vous évader dc oui mais
visionnement c'est pas possible
et quand vous entendez la vie qui passe
à côté tout tous les gens qui nous
entendent et parce qu'on entend les
bruits de la ville dort quel effet cela
vous fait
et quelle impression ça me le fait que
vous êtes arrivé pour la première fois
dans la prison ferme je suis prouvé la
répulsion pour tous puis un dégoût de la
vie j'en avais marre quoi j'ai envie de
claquer
il peut arriver que certains réagissent
très mal à ce décor est au bout d'un
certain temps et des réactions
d'allergie à ce décor évidemment mélanie
pouvant rien c'est une affaire de
justice qui vous dépasse évidemment nous
leur apportons tout le soutien éducatif
qui est en notre possibilité et nous
essayons de leur faire supporter au
mieux les conditions de détention ici
est ce que vous trouvez beaucoup de
jeunes pour le ser ont des gènes et yala
pas mal oui il y en a pas mal l'ont
retrouveront parmi tous ces jeunes dans
les débits de boisson des jeunes qui
sont en fuite les jeunes filles sont en
file des jeunes qui sont évadés de
centres où ils ont été placés des jeunes
qui seront tous oisif qui n'ont aucune
activité aucune occupations habituelles
oui par exemple oui ce sont les jeunes
gens oui elec prenant même apparemment
ce jeune ce jeune
est encore mineur et voyez si l'officier
de police la circonscription l'a fait
monter dans le car c'est qui veut
vérifier d'une façon plus sérieuse
sa situation actuelle alors il va être
conduit au commissariat et tout à
l'heure si rien ne peut être relevée à
ta charge il sera relaxé
oui mais alors tout à l'heure quelque
chose m'a frappé c'est que on a emmené
les jeunes gens et jeunes filles qui est
très vraisemblable pas 1 2 n'a jamais
commis un seul délit dans les a ramenés
au poste de police
parce qu'on appelle vulgairement le
panier à salade et la seule chose qu'on
avait à leur reprocher c'est de ne pas
avoir de papiers d'être dans un café ce
qui n'est en fin de compte à l'interdît
est ce que n'avait pas peur que ces
jeunes soient un peu traumatisé c'est
quand même ça fait drôle d'être arrêté
comme ça et que ça leur donne même des
idées de leurs faces des durs n'ont en
principe ces jeunes savent très bien que
ses rangs deux sont assez fréquentes
qu'elles s'effectuent d'une manière
souple et qu'elles entraînent pour eux
aucun risque car sinon tu rien à se
reprocher ils sont remis en liberté
aussitôt ou pour ceux qui sont entrés
jeunes remis à leurs parents après
vérification les parents sont convoqués
à notre service
on leur fait connaître la situation dans
laquelle s'est trouvée leurs enfants et
on leur remet en main propre quels sont
ceux qui vous font plus peur
les solitaires ou bien alors les groupes
les bandes
en principe les bandes en principe les
bancs ne sont des bandes de jeunes qui
ne sont pas tellement dangereux mais il
arrive toutefois que et on l'a vu trop
souvent ces derniers temps que les
jeunes je veux dire des jeunes de 20 à
22 ans perdent la tête quand nous les
interpellons pour si peu qu'ils aient
commis un délit assez important moi
c'est sérieux qu'il pense qu'on les
recherches pour ça c'est là qu'ils
commettent l'imprudence de temps elle
s'enfuir ou même
chose plus grave à notre rencontre
tout le problème c'est de leur fournir
justement la possibilité d'un dialogue
d'un accueil adultes qui leur manque
il faut que leur quartier qui
généralement une attitude hostile
vis-à-vis de données accueillant aux
problèmes de ces jeunes et le rôle de
l'équipe éducative c'est de transformer
la mentalité du quartier vis-à-vis d'eux
des jeunes de la rue je ne nie pas du
tout je ne nie pas du tout le mérite des
éducateurs d'éducation surveillée et des
services sociaux et je ne nie pas qu'il
soit nécessaire à des moments où pour
certains individus de pratiquer
l'internât mais je pense que plus les
jeunes sont délinquants plus ils sont
inadaptées plus il faut les laisser dans
leur milieu naturel ça semble paradoxal
parce que c'est le milieu dans son
ensemble qu'il faut faire monté
patiemment alors nous d'avant on obtient
des résultats qui apparemment sont peu
importants pendant six mois un an et
aura pas beaucoup de changements dans la
rue la bande que nous préférons
d'ailleurs appelé la horde parce que
band évoque une idée d'organisation
beaucoup trop grande arnaque c'est
plutôt anarchique la bande n'aura pas
beaucoup changé mais les changements à
qui ils seront définitives notre action
c'est essentiellement une relation
d'amitié avec un assez grand nombre de
jeunes qui sont des jeunes de la rue et
parmi lesquels il y a les délinquants
vous avez repéré dans ce quartier telle
ou telle bande qui à l'occasion d'un
événement particulier je ne sais pas une
fait une fête foraine ou même sans
événement particulier au fond vous aller
vers eux je dirais plomb le rentrer dans
le chou dans la mesure où ils sont très
étonné de voir quelqu'un aller vers eux
puisque d'habitude ils font peur un peu
à cause de leur allure extérieure qu'il
cultive deuil et on va vers eux puis je
sais pas on va prendre un pot avec eux
ou alors au contraire on va tirer un
carton si c'est une fête foraine je ne
sais pas quoi est bon là on pose pas
encore trop de problèmes parce que ça
arrive quand même de temps en temps qui
est un type un peu joyeux un peu sympa
qui leur fasse des des choses comme ça
mais c'est quand on revient le lendemain
les voir que on commence à poser un
problème
ils se disent bon pourquoi ce type est
là et
à ce moment là ils cherchent à
l'expliquer à partir de ce que eux
connaissent de ce qui est leur réalité
ils disent bon ben il n'y a pas de
problème ce type là c'est un homosexuel
parce qu'effectivement ils sont
constamment à la merci de la demande de
des homosexuels bon il faut un certain
temps pour qu'il s'aperçoive que ce
n'est pas le cas il faut même longtemps
il faut généralement jusqu'à trois mois
si on n'est pas un homosexuel on est un
flic et là aussi il faut du temps il
faut un mois et demi avant de
s'apercevoir qu'on n'est pas un flic à
moins un mois et demi après bien sûr ça
ça varie beaucoup
il s'en aperçoive aussi dans la réalité
et 50 ils nous ont raconté quand un ou
deux qui a fait une histoire nous la
raconter qu'ils s'aperçoivent que ben on
l'a pas arrêté ni dénoncer ni je ne sais
pas quoi s'aperçoivent bien qu'on n'est
pas un flic et puis à un moment mais ton
six mois au bout de six mois il ya un
moment où pour une dizaine ou une
douzaine de types
on devient je crois qu'on est reconnu
comme un pote un ami leur vocabulaire
est le nôtre varient et je dirais que
pendant ce temps là on fait une démarche
vers nous pour nous reconnaître et nous
avons fait une démarche vers eux
également pour les reconnaître
on ne fait pas le travail qu'on fait
simplement parce qu on a derrière la
tête des idées charitables ou je ne sais
pas quoi en disant il faut aider ces
types là on commence à pouvoir faire ce
travail quand on s'est rendu compte
qu'il n'est pas question de les aider
mais je dirais bêtement de les aimer et
d'être aimé par eux à la limite ce n'est
pas la limite il ya d'être aimé par eux
c'est mauvais ça c'est un schéma si vous
voulez parce que la réalité est
drôlement plus vivante que ça est
drôlement plus dans les deux sens je
veux dire que je leur pose des questions
certainement mais il m'en pose sacrément
aussi justement sur ce à quoi
finalement je peux croire aux profondes
- quel genre de la question les
questions que me pose c'est que
vis-à-vis de ces jeunes qui dansent dans
beaucoup de cas ont commis des délits
et puis qui je dirais un petit peu en
commet talent à longueur de journée à
saint des choses que on est habitués à
considérer comme immoral ou amoral on se
dit que quand même on a un sacré paquet
de
deux jugements moraux pénible et pesant
et qu'on considère les moindres petites
choses comme comme à morales ou comme il
ya des choses qu'on fait pas sur les ca
vous décapent je dirais sur le plan
moral ont fini par savoir à quoi on
croit vraiment parce que qu'un type aa
john est un disque dans un prise unique
je m'en fous c'est vraiment comme ça je
m'en fous complètement
ça ne le définit en aucune façon
alors qu'au fond il ya trois ans quand
j'ai commencé à faire ce travail
un type qui veut quelque chose à prise
unique c'était mal et j'avais beau
essayer de intellectuellement de le
comprendre je le comprenais pas de tout
moi même si vous voulez alors que
maintenant
oui je peux dire que oui à ce qui est
possible d'être facilement copain avec
des gens qui par exemple c'est mon vote
électoral sont différents de vous ils
sont pas différents de nous au niveau
intellectuel et sens différent au niveau
scolaire
c'est à dire que fectivement je fais des
études supérieures eux pas mais je suis
persuadé que ils ont des quotients
intellectuels absolument normaux j'ai
même l'impression qui est pas mal de
type qui sont surdoué le parmi ces
jeunes de la rue ils sont une employée
c'est tout le problème cauris quand vous
avez dit de moi que je suis un étudiant
vous n'avez rien dit de moi simplement
que je suis inscrit à l'université quand
vous avez dit d'eux qu'ils sont des
délinquants vous avez dit d'eux qu'ils
sont inscrits sur le registre d'une
prison qui l'ont été mais c'est tout
sont des hommes c'est à dire que monde
sont des hommes qui sont passés par chez
un juge mais c'est un accident c'est une
péripétie comme on est vous définissez
pas quelqu'un en disant qu'il a visités
carcassonne bien sûr que passer dans une
prison c'est pas neutre c'est pas comme
visiter carcassonne c'est sûr que ça
marque un type ce sont des types
extrêmement vivant qui ont des tas de
capacités et ses capacités ils ont
besoin de s'exprimer quand on a 14 ans
ou entre 14 et 20 ans on pète le feu il
pète le feu
donc si vous voulez cesser ils ont
besoin d'épancher des forces de deux
d'envoyer leurs forces
quelque part ils les envoyaient là
dedans nous on essaye de proposer autre
chose dont ils retireront plus de
satisfactions on leur propose pas de
faire du parachutisme puisque nous en
faisant de la plongée sous-marine du
karaté de l'électronique des camps avec
un vieux bus
ou n'importe quoi la propose 2 propose
pas ce genre de choses simplement pour
éviter qu'ils avaient cassé les vitres
des commerçants je dirais encore je m'en
fous on leur propose ceci simplement
parce que ils en trouveront ils auront
là l'occasion de s'affronter à une
réalité et il tire ont beaucoup plus de
satisfaction et c'est socialement moins
dangereux ce que je disais tout à
l'heure que de casser les vitres c'est à
dire que les emmènera pas en prison
c'est important pour le palais en prison
[Musique]